[Music]
hey what's going on everybody
denne direct oh here thank you for
joining us for a special live version of
the daily Denny with me oh we're so
lucky to be graced by the presence of a
t-zone Kelty night I was on vogue
yesterday but what I wore to the SAG
Awards but that doesn't matter anymore
because now I'm on daily Denny and like
it's my wishes r-truth invited me you
you know what thank you for being here
say hello to the Internet I love this
man so much and we just came up with our
greatest idea ever we're gonna make mugs
that when you put them full of hot
drinks his hair goes up doesn't even
when you have no drink the hair goes
down there's want some day lead any
merch I think you should have it anyways
besides my merch and my brand we are
here to talk about the SAG Awards that
happened last night and we are lucky to
have kiltie here because last night
you're on the red carpet it was so much
fun a lot of glitz a lot of glam I don't
think anyone had more fun than you on
the right car I had the best time of my
life I mean I'm on the giant et golden
gilded stage the stars literally wait in
line to come talk to UTA they're just
like oh you're not available Cal just
wait and you're like okay I'll try to
hurry and the everyone came up everyone
was in such a good mood
I mean there was of course those
undertones of like everything's going on
in Hollywood lately but I think people
were like gonna wear color right I'm
gonna live my best life and like I'm
gonna have fun tonight there's a little
more freewheeling a little fun and
you're ready to catch and receive like
it was so much fun to watch it you know
we're actually gonna break down all
those fashion looks in just a minute so
stick around and of course we'll be
getting you guys's comments right here
to this iPad but first I want to talk
about some of Kelty's red carpet
interviews because one they were fire to
you know normally at these things we're
trying to pull news out of people in the
case of Allison Janney you actually
broke news to her yes so one of the
things that was kind of happening while
I was on the car on the way to the SAG
Awards was that this Olivia Munn on a
ferris thing had been going on and I was
getting updates so one of our main
things was like oh let's get like
Allison Janney who is of course on mom
with Otto Faris to talk about it so when
I asked her about it she had no idea
what was going on so I said to her so I
had to go what happened was it
so basically let me tell you what
happened so basically we had an
eyewitness see Olivia Munn and Chris
Pratt on a romantic 'old eight will be
raised well P they film things were
going on people saw them together
hanging out then they were at a party
and Allison Janney was actually at that
party so they were all hanging out then
of course the rumor else started olivia
Montecristi odd on item weather maybe it
was just a first date it's too early an
item we don't know well you know this
town exactly they were seen together
they're dating so then Olivia Munn
I guess felt weird about it so she
texted on affairs because they're
friends and she was like hey are all
like I I don't usually like fall into
tabloid fodder but you know I just want
you know that the rumors are 100% not
true and like I would never say anything
but I know you I want to be cool which I
thought was like ultimate girls girl
move girls go moving then she shared
that text screenshot so then on a fare
strikes back and she's like listen it
would have been totally cool I would
have loved to have used sister-in-law
like they're like best buddies they're
using all kinds of colorful emojis
everything was good and I think it was
really cool and then they shared it so
we can all stop talking about it except
that we're talking about it yeah exactly
well Allison Janney had no clue about it
but she had the best response to that
whole situation we actually have it for
you guys here take a look they still
love and respect each other very much so
I think they would be happy for she
would be happy for him to find someone
and he
and she has about someone so I they're
just lovely people and Olivia is a
lovely person too so I'm glad they they
didn't let some tabloid or whatever and
I don't know who put that out but I'm
glad they put out the fire before before
it got out of hand I love how much
honour and Alison after working together
on mom just like rep each other she's my
best friend's reputation big reputation
oh you and me you know I said we needed
to perform during this live and at the
beginning moving right along to some
other dating fodder Madeleine Brewer of
hand mate still was spotted on a date
excuse me I should say dinner dinner
wouldn't take Jonah say you actually
asked her about it a hundred a stir
about you first of all she looked
gorgeous at the second horse she's so
beautiful and I was like well I can see
why Nick Jonas asked you out girl so I
asked her about it and do we have the
clip dude yeah well here you go
headlines about you ila so what's
happening are you dating Nick or wine oh
no we I ate food across from each other
okay so about Hollywood that's a date I
guess so I guess so
but it was um he's really nice he's a
nice guy not official but a fun time no
he was her friend
you said you'd though he's adorable yeah
I mean that's just like objectively yeah
he's a cute guy yeah yeah don't quote
her it's just objectively you know like
he's he's a really nice guy we're
friends
can I go yeah it was definitely on and
Jonas dates a lot of people I'm just
gonna say like Nick Jonas is not scared
about asking a Hollywood starlet out to
a date so it's not official but they
were on a date there was a giant wine
glass you can see how nervous she was
I'm glad you just went for it though
yeah we'd keep an eye on those two is
what I'm saying
Nick Camaro right I like them together I
do like the shoes boy just doing that
could we were talking about how pretty
shoes your face and like can I treat
everything with you please oh and that
ear cuff okay fashioned later fashions
coming up but first guys I just had to
share this moment with you with Kelty
and Goldie Hawn and Kate Hudson it was a
real fashion moment a real bonding
moment between these three take a look I
could be in the color story of the vogue
layout of us
like if we were like I'll just be
another daughter beyond their daughter
and my right okay you know what I quit I
gotta go to Vogue shoot I told you she
had the most fun at the side whenever
Kate Hudson's dress was insane and she
came up and I was like oh god okay good
ruffles and pink is gonna because
whatever she wears she's always on the
best-dressed list so like I had kind of
a ridiculous dress on to it a lot of
ruffle and a peak and I was like I'm
safe yeah okay good they're gonna put us
together ruffles and pink was a trend
Kate Hudson were ruffled MP dress I wore
a dress
wow it's your year no she's really funny
and the funniest part that you didn't
see and that is that when she came up I
said to Kate I was talking about her
dress and a sec oh my god would you give
it because it was just i dropping you
know and then goldie sitting there and
she goes I'm also wearing a dress and I
was like oh I'm sorry and she's like I
picked this dress because and she was
like I need my attention - so the two of
them together it is like the Apple does
not fall far from the tree right there
now speaking of Kate's look we want to
talk about the fashion now you guys
obviously after the blackout at the
Golden Globes you know where all these
stars wore black in solidarity at the
SAG Awards is way more freewheeling a
little fun you saw some shimmer I saw
some color I learned some things so
first of all there was a lot of very
artsy dresses you know sometimes people
go real sexy this was like everyone came
to play with like an artisanal moment so
spray tan is out yep everyone was pale
everyone was leaving their chic life
Kate Hudson was in the Valentino dress
what you didn't probably notice at home
is that it was pink who's fluttered had
the belt had the neck the heart those
polka dots on it were actually hearts
and each one of those hearts was velvet
yeah so it added to like a whole nother
level of her I mean this dress is
ridiculous I can't I love it
no no pixie cut I love it I have to say
I feel like that look was a little
polarizing online but it totally works
with her hair her makeup was flawless
and I feel like anyone else maybe
wouldn't be able to pull that off but
key Hudson ace she's the Nicole Kidman
Gucci peacock dress address of this year
it's very her she's so bubbly and fun
and loving like that was her ha she
she's obsessed applies I think she even
told you that she
it's her mom for that lifelong passion
for Pilates they both look good aging
backwards alright moving on to Reese
Witherspoon and Zac Posen
I love this dress on her because of the
color and I gotta say I'm not sure we've
ever seen this kind of cut or silhouette
on her but it just seems like such a
Reese Witherspoon gown what did you
think like if I wore this dress and I
was a bridesmaid in a wedding I would be
like I don't know about this color in
this print and then when Reese
Witherspoon wears that I'm like god
she's beautiful like I loved it I
thought she was so beautiful and she
said she was Zach Posen and she said you
know was really important to her to
support designers that had supported the
times of movement so he had donated and
so she wears that pose in and it was
beautiful and also can I just tell the
people I don't know watching tell them
like Reese Witherspoon in person is so
beautiful like you have not experienced
this kind of beauty yeah in your life
when you're this cluster you're like do
you have a poor no is your skin perfect
like she's just like she is Elle Woods I
not only does she look that good but
she's just like this because she
actually shared a little Instagram story
prepping for the big night for the red
carpet and she's eating freaking french
fries for dinner
guys like only Reese Witherspoon will
begin her makeup done like she's about
to squeeze into his AK Posen dress and
she's just downing some friends having
some fries having actually added car Bob
she told you that nice car buff and I
appreciate that about her not blame her
when you're not beautiful you can just
you know and it's a long night it's a
long freaking night all right one of
your favorites Margot Robbie in yeah go
crazy fan Grover Margo what is she
wearing
okay Margot Robbie is so beautiful she's
wearing muumuu and I just like I okay
she's so effortless like you can tell
some of the women of Hollywood they
really have to try I feel like Margaux
was like oh my god I'll go get coffee
with my friend and then I'll put on this
dress with feathers and I'll just go
like she never looks overdone like her
hair is so effortless like I tried to do
my hair like that today it didn't work
out the same but I love the high waist
it's kind of like with the feathers and
I just think this is like she's having
her moment she has
been winning for I Tanya even though she
was so fabulous but she's like I don't
care because I'm the most beautiful
person on the planet well that in such a
proud moment because she's also an
executive producer of the movie so she's
like I'm gonna show up and turn out and
also you're a showgirl so I know you
love those feathers no it was but there
was actually a lot of like feather
detail and likeness accoutrements last
night oh all right let's move on to our
girl Mary J bless she's also having such
an amazing year of course being
recognized for her acting she rocked a
designer I've never heard of Jean Louie
Sivaji yes guys and look at her look at
her body look at her body she is like
dripping in this dress she told me it
was so tight she couldn't walk in it she
had like a platform shoe that was like
at least six inches on but she knows she
looks good like she was so confident but
I love the way the white like this is a
great lesson for ladies like you do a
big accoutrement on the top and then
that simple black I mean her little
champagne glass body is just dripping in
that see some hard time walking because
that's what you don't see on TV that
part in between the poses yeah people
may not know she's stabbed by La Roche
who stars in day out Jamie Lalonde yes
and Celine Dion so they like live for a
red carpet moment and that was a moment
and you know that's another person who
told me that she is dieting me this
award season but she's ready to eat she
told you a few weeks that's right
tomorrow Oscar nomination she might have
to keep that day going for a couple
weeks more yeah I want to talk about
Mandy Moore because girl looked flawless
in a word flawless last night she was
wearing custom Ralph Lauren in this like
cobalt blue number but I loved
everything about this look the hair the
makeup like I don't know what that lip
is I'm sure some concoction striker does
her makeup in Hollywood we need a how to
Hollywood on this Hollywood exactly I'm
shook on this like no she looks amazing
she's so again it's like she's so
effortless know people might at home
might not realize many mores really tall
I think she's like five eight so she has
like a supermodel body you know she's
she's really tall so she can wear these
just like I'm just gonna throw on a slip
dress and go which I love but it was so
comfy on her too she just looked so
happy and men are we happy for this is
Ashwini I love this is
no by the time I got home from the red
carpet I was in my living room just in
time to watch it I was like because like
what are you doing and I was like I'm so
happy for them just like yurts
listen I don't think Mandy has gotten
enough recognition for her performance
and this is us I was happy to see or at
least get rewarded with the ensemble
last night in fact Peter the ensemble
the girls of this is us turned it out
together this is apparently unplanned
but they all wore the same kind of blue
the three women leads in this is us
that's that's them right there um they
said wasn't planned but I've kind of
like a on-the-nose coincidence that what
you think I mean it's insane
that all three of them were but this is
a great power color you know and what
happens sometimes in the designer world
is that a color becomes really popular
like everyone all the designers are
doing yellow and the fabrics like way
way back at the beginning of the chain
like these kinds of silks and suffer
being shown and so every designer makes
a dress in this color but the weird
thing is is that Chrissy Mets his dress
was Kate Kate Kate Hudson Kate Spade
custom so they would have had to make
that it wouldn't even been on a rack and
so I don't know yeah Mandy's was
customed to so I just wanted like the
stylists are texting each other like
what color you wear they said it wasn't
planned Mandy said it wasn't playing
they're like Destiny's Child like one of
them had a different like more dot part
of the dress but again I feel like when
you're going from wearing black up the
Golden Globes you're gonna pick like a
power color and why not go with blue the
Beyonce of it I'm not answering that I
mean I love that Kelly
oh wait DeeDee here says I need more
Mandy Moore and custom electric blue
Ralph Lauren don't we all don't we all
she's beautiful and I really like one of
the things um it's an interesting makeup
thing on Mandy so her eyeshadow goes
right from her eyeline all the way up to
her eyebrow that's like a very like late
80s early 90s thing and on her it looks
so beautiful that's like instead of the
smoky eye did you see how like shadowy
it is there's a gonna do their plays in
with her beautiful hair and like I want
to make all the ladies at home feel
better I'm 99% would believe most of
that hair is not Mandy horsehair that's
fair so don't feel bad about your
blowout when you go to the whatever bar
you go to and get your blowout and
you're like oh my god I don't look like
that that's because she's got like all
kinds of pieces and you can too
some hair you'll be fine Hollywood
secrets oh look back hairdo last night
was from Kristen Bell she was our host
of the night and she had multiple looks
last night but the one that she hit the
red carpet in was a J Mendel and I think
I freaking love Kristen Bell um but I
thought this was a very classic like
pretty look a little safe but it works
for her this is so okay
first about you were amazing I'm
obsessed with you
I thought she might do something a
little more fun she's like the hostess
with roses it's a SAG Awards as part
this to me is like an Oscars gown but I
love the color she looks beautiful
I will tell everyone that before the
show you know usually the host will come
and do some interviews with some outlets
and stuff she didn't do any uh and
people were like she's just so nervous
she's like can't she's doing study her
notes or whatever so that's very sweet I
thought she looked beautiful I thought
it was a little formal for this egg
party but then she killed it on that
when she did the ship oh my god all
kinds of we have one of those photos
that she swore she wore a couple custom
Reem Acra x' and then also Yanina
couture gown but yeah they were black
and really beautiful and she like for
love more partying yeah it was a party
inside it was afraid it's a lot of
pressure when you're the host first ever
yes and then also it's like so in the
past Golden Globes all the women usually
wore sparkles and then sex was color and
then Oscars is like ball gown ridiculous
extreme so with the Golden Globes going
black it really kind of created there
wasn't really a trend of the night
people didn't really know what to wear
exactly but I think that's actually made
it for way more fun and easy on the eye
carpet and I don't mean because people
took risks you always see that kind of
shimmer in the color at the Grammys yeah
I mean but yeah Kristen Bell actually
made history last night she was the
first SAG Awards host ever the first to
do it but there's actually a couple of
history makers last night we want to
talk about including Julia Louie Dreyfus
who won her eighth and ninth SAG Award
for V Plus and I as part of the ensemble
and of course her lean comedic
performance she knows the most SAG
Awards of any actor in SAG Awards
history jld I fangirl for you I love you
know it's crazy and when you see her
cast of course she's been battling
breast cancer she's just finished
chemotherapy and she couldn't be there
she was watching in her PJs which is
very sweet when you talk to her cast you
can tell that she's such a leader that
people really love her she really is
captain of that ship and you would kind
of missed her yesterday seeing her
energy and everything so but of course
we're sending her well wishes and and it
was cool because the cast was there and
they finally won - would've been a
minute and so um it's great it was a
good moment and you know what I did miss
Julia Louie Dreyfus last night because
she always has such funny speeches and
it's kind of hard to believe there's
only one more season of veep and it's it
but something tells me we're gonna be
seeing her for a long time and also some
of the cast told me that they are not
against a spinoff there you go
see ya love a spinoff in Hollywood we'll
spin things like five or six times no
they're totally dead not now we'll see
you in 10 years yeah
all right sterling came Brown and this
is us also made history last night he
was the first black man to win the SAG
Award for Best Actor in a Drama Series
for this is us and also the cast one for
Best ensemble and here's what happened
is sterling right after that moment they
called us we looked around at each other
right I really like this is happening
I've ripped my jacket you did on that oh
I totally ripped my jacket I think I
sweat it through my shirt it's right
there it's right there I know no chill
like sorry to mr. Armani for ripping
your clothes but that's by the way that
only happens when you jack that will
never happen me like I'll never know
I'll never hold out of my clothes you
also won't ever be carrying two SAG
Awards maybe you are dream big Danny you
know what you're right hey Danny
you know what this is my year guys this
mayor can I just like give a shout-out
Stern came around okay there are people
in Hollywood that are so talented he's
beyond town - oh good he's been nicest
man like I think that's why everyone is
so happy for him when he wins consider
like he's always winning stuff he's that
good but it's like he came up and he was
like oh hey count see and he had Tom
Ford sunglasses on I was like you rockin
those Tom's I was like thanks for
noticing I mean he's just like a
goodtime guy I wonder if he's like a
total jerk when he gets home or
something because like how do you how
are you that nice all the time something
told me he is not you know what I mean
he's just so lovable so charming and
you're right freaking talented I've
never seen I haven't seen a man do the
single cry tears bat well in a very very
take me to the church and there being a
black panther I know you asked me like I
can't get tickets this is why I was like
can you get tickets she's like well I
got a ticket but like I don't know I'm
like okay fine like it's instance
sterling is here no so how did Jack die
oh you know what the cast actually gave
us some some secrets on that death yeah
and that's how about et online.com so
make sure you guys go check it out
that's all we have time for thank you so
much for coming hanging out with this
you guys there's plenty more tonight on
ET they're breaking down the fashion
what you didn't see on TV I have a very
exciting thing to tell us okay so tune
in to ET tonight on TV so what we did is
we had a lot of celebrity couples there
yesterday and we asked them how they
first met which is weird that it is not
out public like public knowledge we have
the sweetest stories about how these
celebs first met or when they first saw
one of them is like relationship you
like rom-com Entertainment Tonight
rom-com is happening on the show tonight
so please tune in absolutely and of
course you guys there's plenty more SAG
Awards coverage over at et online.com
thank you so much for tuning in and make
sure you guys watch us next week because
we're gonna be recapping the Grammy
Awards ok this was such a pleasure -
pleasure Kelty thank you so much Oh what
up
all right guys love you so much thanks
for watching we'll see you guys tomorrow
with a brand new daily ditty
[Music]
you
[Music]